the Continental Tire Coach's Corner
brings us the manager of the Dodgers
Dave Roberts congratulations on the
contract extension was there any doubt
about this no no it was kind of just
something that we knew in Everett
ability was going to happen but
obviously the season gets in the way and
takes priority and then you get to the
postseason and the offseason we have you
know we lost coach here so you're trying
to backfill but ultimately Dan we know
is gonna get done and I couldn't be
happier to represent the progress do you
treat yourself do I treat myself so my
wife and I shared a nice bottle of red
wine and maybe I'm hoping for a good
Christmas gift for my wife but no no you
know I I haven't treated myself I don't
know she tells me all the time I thought
we should okay how about you go get
another watch another watch yeah all
right so what so what what should I get
I'm always in the market for a new watch
well I love Panerai as do I autumn are
is is sleek I've got one of those how
about just a nice sensible Timex so just
go old-school
yeah or Seiko just something that's you
know just timeless something like that
that's right I might do that all right I
could wrap my I could wrap it what about
a current exit watch and that's a
surfing company right yeah it's a
lifestyle brand okay yeah yeah but I
could I could go Timex I could go Timex
I might I might do that
bring it back retro by the way
congratulations on Wine Spectator given
you a 95 points the red stitch the cab
that you got you came out with yeah
that's right and you know what I need a
hold of mine of the deal dead because I
just said you some wine so thank you
very much and our Cabernet got a 95
point score from Spectator and drinking
really well right now but obviously can
age but I need to send you some wines
you could really sample it and I want to
learn your palate
okay yeah I'm a red wine guy i okay
couple things baseball wise have you
looked back do watch games postseason
games playoff games series games I do
not I have it pretty much forged in my
brain and I'm a pretty visual person so
in a pretty good memory so to go back
and watch it I haven't put myself
through that
what is forged in your memory that you
can't get rid of
[Music]
well the 18-inning game which which was
I try to tend to look at some of the
positives so the 80 inning winning game
the performances and obviously there's
things that you could have done
different that you wonder if that could
have influenced things and you know I
think as a manager you're always kind of
you have opportunities to kind of pull
strings and impact the game players play
the game players it's about the players
but you know you always kind of
second-guess if it doesn't go right what
was it like when you went up to Clayton
Kershaw and said you're not starting
Game one of the World Series so that was
in the that was in the division series
and it was yeah and it was you know what
Clayton it was kind of a deep breath
wanting to know why and us given them
our reasons and he took it like a pro
and and he came back in game 2 and
dominated and I and I thought it proved
to be the right decision but even if it
didn't work out we felt it was the right
decision for our club at that point in
time what was your reaction when you saw
the Diamondbacks traded Paul Goldschmidt
a little bit of exhale and a little
smile and it's it's good to see that guy
out of our division because Dan this guy
he's one of my favorite players on the
other side and how he approaches a game
plays a game plays every pitched and so
to get him out of the West
I'll let the Cubs and Joe gladdened deal
with them for 18 times why is Manny
Machado not going to be back with the
Dodgers well it's not done
you know Manny's a man he's free and
heck of a play a really good good young
man
so III don't even know if that's the
case you know he has that opportunity so
we'll see how the winner plays doubt
yeah I had issues with him with some of
these quotes and you know as a manager
you know you can't sit down one of your
players when he doesn't run hard and
then you got somebody who says he's not
a Johnny hustle kind of guy how do you
how do you manage a situation like that
okay so that's fair but it's a
conversation it's an adult conversation
and I will say this Dan is like there's
a little bit with and Manny's English is
very good but there's a little bit of
lost in translation in that and I talked
to him right after the comments and what
he meant was I don't want to play for I
wash and and and do things to hustle
just a hustle not that I'm not
justifying it because the way I played
the game I hustled every play he is he
does conserve but he didn't mean it in
the way that he doesn't like the hustle
but the bottom line is that yeah he
knows he used to play a little bit
harder at times for sure yeah
Bryce Harper you are you allowed to talk
about these players I don't want you get
in trouble you know what I got
reprimanded a couple years ago talked
about a guy wasn't free oh I think I
can't talk about Bryce I keep free now
so yeah what a player what a player have
you talked to him and his magic talk to
I have not talked to him okay his magic
you know what I don't know from from the
the narrative and kind of as it reads
certain storylines that I guess magic
talk to but I haven't talked to magic or
Bryce so I don't even know if that maybe
even took place yet but I do know we're
going to Vegas for the Winter Meetings
and and that's what I do know Bryce
Harper watches this show so if you would
like for me to be the immediate me
Thierry is there something you would
like to say to Bryce Harper
he knows what I think and and you can I
can kind of sway with wine yeah conduit
how much wine would you have to give up
to get Bryce Harper though you only made
300 cases of your wine would you write
all 300 cases to get Bryce Harper and
myself yeah your question I don't even
know if he drinks wine but you know
that'd be nice a signing bonus you get
you get wine and it's in at your lawn we
can work I think Marc Walter would
really love that what that would get it
done
Dave Roberts the Dodgers manager joining
us Continental Tire coaches corner we
were talking about baseball with this
shift and it feels like we might be
moving away from the shift in baseball
what would you do if the Commissioner
asked you your opinion you okay with a
shift in baseball I am I am I think that
you know it puts your impetus on the
player to to go out there and and beat
the shift and you know whether it's a
drop in a bunt down or manipulating the
bat to get a base it the other way I
think then it's interesting is there's
compensation obviously in baseball with
slugging percentage and home runs and
things like that and so hitters are now
trying to hit over the shift or hit
through it and swing harder and now you
get the swing in this where sometimes
the manipulation a base hit a run you
know to keep the line moving but I think
to your question I really I'm okay with
this ship I think the players need to
make the adjustment yeah I'm right there
with you I don't it just feels like
that's part of baseball that I want to
take advantage of what you don't do well
you know I don't need to level the
playing field here like it that'd be
like somebody who doesn't hit the
curveball and you're gonna go hey no
more curveballs that's unfair I got to
make you adjust I got to make you want
to get better that's exactly what I got
it and I see it's
you know you watch the game from the
from the bench or you see overhead
pictures and you see when a guy gets a
strike on them and there's one guy on
the left side of the infield and yeah
and you're down a run and you know the
hitter doesn't want to give himself up
or take that chance and that's on the
coaching too you know as far as making
guys practice something so once you
practice it you get better at it you
have more about the confidence to
execute it in a big league game so
you're on the coaching myself that's
something that we internally we're gonna
get better at as a Dodger Club and that
that's on me if I gave you one mulligan
and you have to take the Mulligan but
one Mulligan for this past season
I would probably I would have had that
conversation with Rich Hill in the in
the fifth inning I think it was and I
would have just made him feel like
Superman and had him really try to
finish that inning what did you say to
him that I'm gonna keep an eye on them
and you know we're gonna go hit her to
hit her knowing that this is that's the
mostly ever through but I would have
really tried to eliminate coming out of
that inning and really support them to
get through it in any way possible
why do managers sometimes manage
differently in the postseason well I
know there's more states there's more at
stake it's a shorter series you have
different things at your disposal and
you know it is interesting again is when
managers don't and it doesn't go well
but the other side the criticism is you
have to manage difference in the
postseason and then what you do man is
different and it doesn't go well you get
the question why do you managers man is
different in the posting so it's all
kind of you
to look back right that fair and it's a
look back where I think that as an
organization and a philosophy on what
you feel is going to give you the best
chance to win that particular game
that's what you have to do in every
manager every organization is different
for us unfortunately it didn't work out
but you know I still thought we had a
very successful season yeah I was
critical of some of the moves you made
in the moment there were a couple of
ongoing wait what are you doing here
and then then you watch what you know
counsel did with the Brewers and you're
going wait what my kids it's kind of
crazy now they you know the old school
is you know it's that's gone it feels
like an on how to manage you know it
does that's fair again but I think that
if you look at the World Series champion
this year Alice Corps did the same thing
so and even more so when you're when
you're talking about starters finishing
games or a starter pitching in a game
and coming back and throwing five or six
innings and two days or a day of rest
and throwing six innings shutout and
obviously he threw really well but
that's unorthodox but it worked out so
it's in there certain situations that it
didn't work out but they ended up
performing and ultimately there's
nothing said about it that's baseball
because if it's in sports it's really
result driven and that's the way it
should be but are you in the playoffs
how much is gut feeling and how much is
analytics it's a combo and I think that
that's that and that's the regular
season
that's the postseason I think that the
regular the post office Lee is more
scrutinized and you know looked at it
and really dissected but I would say you
know every manager has or should have a
blend what to what degree what
percentage I really can't speak to it I
really don't know Dan I mean each game
is different I mean some games it's 75%
25% analytic some games it's 50/50 so
every game is different every situation
is different
how does the family deal with the
criticism you know if they read
something
here's something do they tell you so my
wife does a very good job she doesn't
she's not completely current but what
she does get she's very comical about it
and there's these memes I guess are
called me so and she loves to show me
this percent up and add comic release
and I don't always see the humor in
these memes but she does which is great
I yeah hi kids we've been forced to grow
up quicker because when they're hearing
bad things about their father that's got
to be tough I didn't have to deal with
that as a kid they handle it well that's
part of the thing I'm probably most
sensitive to but this is what we signed
up for us or I signed up for they didn't
but they kind of they kind of understand
it well congrats on the season the
contract extension and maybe we'll cross
paths in spring training but thanks for
joining us David alright and makes you
tell Todd to send me your address so I
can finish the wine alright alright
thank you thank you Dave that's a Dave
Roberts yeah I have sometimes pickup
Wine Spectator and I have a friend Teddy
who's always telling me about you know
wines and he'll go you know Dave Roberts
has a Cabernet called red stitch it got
95 points from Wine Spectator they went
oh okay the red stitch stitches on a
baseball in case you're wondering
they're Continental Tire Coach's Corner
Continental Tire proud to be the
exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick show
no matter where you drive what you drive
Continental designs tires for what you
do for more information visit
Continental Tire calm down little tire
for what you do for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
at
you